The traditional approach to supporting
different devices is to make an app for
each device and platform as they
become available and adopted by users.
This has typically meant
a new project for each and
every device developed and
supported independently.
For most of us, we actually think of
the experience on any of these devices
as part of a single whole experience for
the user with our service.
Approaching each as
a separate project is well,
it's just the wrong way to go about it.
Instead you're going to want to
think about having a view
into your service from every
device that makes sense.
Now this is really the definition
of ubiquitous computing
where your service is available
anywhere and everywhere.
Each view into your service
will differ slightly
depending on the features available, and
what the user needs in that context, but
taken as a whole these views lead
to a single seamless experience for
the user across their life.